what's happening with the next stage of
lockdown second Cape thanks so much
because the Prime Minister is here good
morning I'm sorry I've been away from my
desk for much longer than I would have
liked and I want to thank everybody who
has stepped up in particular the
Secretary of State Dominick Rob who's
done a terrific job but once again I
want to thank you the people of this
country for the sheer grit and guts
you've shown and are continuing to show
every day I know that this virus springs
new sadness and mourning to households
across the land and it is still true
that this is the biggest single
challenge this country has faced since
the war and I in no way minimize the
continuing problems we face and yet it
is also true that we are making progress
with fewer hospital admissions fewer
Kovac patients in ICU and real signs now
that we are passing through the peak and
thanks to your forbearance your good
sense your altruism your spirit of
community thanks to our collective
national resolve we are on the brink of
achieving that first clear mission to
prevent our National Health Service from
being overwhelmed in a way that
tragically we have seen elsewhere and
that is how and why we are now beginning
to turn the tide if this virus were a
physical assailant an unexpected and
invisible mugger which I can tell you
from personal experience it is then this
is the moment when we have begun
together to wrestle it to the floor and
so it follows that this is the moment of
opportunity
this is the moment when we can press
home our advantage it is also the moment
of maximum risk because I know there
will be many people looking now at our
apparent success and beginning to wonder
whether now is the time to go easy on
those social distancing measures and I
know how hard and how stressful it has
been to give up even temporarily those
ancient and basic freedoms not seeing
friends not seeing loved ones working
from home managing the kids worrying
about your job and your firm so let me
say directly also to British business to
the shopkeepers to the entrepreneurs to
the hospitality sector to everyone on
whom our economy depends I understand
your impatience I share your anxiety and
I know that without our private sector
without the drive and commitment of the
wealth creators of this country there
will be no economy to speak of
there will be no cash to pay for our
public services no way of funding our
NHS and yes I can see the long-term
consequences of Lakhdar as clearly as
anyone and so yes I entirely share your
urgency it's the government's urgency
and yet we must also recognize the risk
of a second spike the risk of losing
control of that virus and letting the
reproduction rate go back over one
because that would mean not only a new
wave of death and disease but also an
economic disaster and we would be forced
once again to slam on the brakes across
the whole country and the whole economy
and reimpose restrictions
in such a way as to do more and lasting
damage and so I know it is tough and I
want to get this economy moving as fast
as I can but I refuse to throw away all
the effort and the sacrifice of the
British people and to risk a second
major outbreak and huge loss of life and
the overwhelming of the NHS and I ask
you to contain your impatience because I
believe we are coming now to the end of
the first phase of this conflict and in
spite of all the suffering we have so
nearly succeeded we defied so many
predictions we did not run out of
ventilators or ICU beds we did not allow
our NHS to collapse and on the contrary
we have so far collectively shielded our
NHS so that our incredible doctors and
nurses and healthcare staff have been
able to shield all of us from an
outbreak that would have been far worse
and we collectively flattened the peak
and so when we're sure that this first
phase is over and that we're meeting our
five tests deaths falling NHS protected
rate of infection down rarely sorting
out the challenges of testing and PPE
avoiding a second peak then that will be
the time to move on to the second phase
in which we continue to suppress the
disease and keep the reproduction rate
the our rate down but begin gradually to
refine the economic and social
restrictions and one by one too far up
the engines of this vast UK economy and
in that process difficult judgments will
be made and we simply cannot spell out
now how fast or slow or even when those
changes will be made though clearly the
government will be
much more about this in the coming days
and I want to serve notice now that
these decisions will be taken with the
maximum possible transparency and I want
to share all our working and our
thinking my thinking with you the
British people and of course we will be
relying as ever on the science to inform
us as we have from the beginning but we
will also be reaching out to build the
biggest possible consensus across
business across industry across all
parts of our United Kingdom across party
lines bringing in opposition parties as
far as we possibly can because I think
that's no less than what the British
people would expect and I can tell you
now that preparations are underway and
have been for weeks to allow us to win
phase two of this fight as I believe we
are now on track to prevail in phase one
and so I say to you finally if you can
keep going in the way that you have kept
going so far if you can help protect our
NHS to save lives and if we as a country
can show the same spirit of optimism and
energy shown by captain Tom Moore who
turns a hundred this week if we can
share the same spirit of unity and
determination as we've all shown in the
past six weeks then I have absolutely no
doubt that we will beat it together we
will come through this all the faster
and the United Kingdom will emerge
stronger than ever before thank you all
very much prime minister you live on Sky
News how you feeling
Prime Minister Kate mechanic